we're expecting a big announcement from
the government on the NHS because we
know there is a big problem and new data
analyzed by our data and forensics team
can tell us just how big it is this is
the picture on the front line in
accident and emergency centers now
patients going to a e are supposed to
wait no more than four hours that's the
target there are 111 NHS trusts in
England from April 2021 to March 2022
not a single one met that for our Target
so what's going on here you might assume
that demand is up the AES are being
swamped with patients well no this chart
shows the number of people going to
Nanny is actually at its lowest since
2017 not including that pandemic years
and those numbers have been pretty
steady over the years but this is how
long people are waiting for more than
four hours and the number waiting for
more than 12 hours for the first time
ever that was nearly 1 million people
you can see it's gone up quite sharply
so I think what you get from that this
isn't just just a hangover from the
pandemic people's waiting times up there
have been increasing over the years even
though the number of people going today
hasn't so much now that is the big
picture but there are important
differences depending on where you live
now again no trust made their wasting
time targets but Sheffield children's
NHS Foundation trust came closest nearly
95 percent of people were seen within
four hours barking havering and
Redbridge on the other hand in East
London performed the worst nearly
two-thirds of people a hundred thousand
people out of a hundred and fifty seven
thousand waited more than four hours to
be seen so geography makes a difference
but so does something like the time of
day and this is the percentage of people
waiting for more than four hours and it
depends on when you show up to a e so
you've got the start of the day here in
towards the midday all the way through
to the early hours what you can see from
that is waiting times get worse pretty
steadily as the day goes on that might
be because people who attend a e late at
night are more likely to be in a serious
condition which requires complex
treatment but if you wake up feeling ill
you might be better off rushing to any
first thing in the morning over here
rather than waiting around until
lunchtime and one last thing I want to
take you through is this it shows the
most people in the people in the most
deprived areas this column here they
used a e centers twice as much three
million people as those in the least of
privateers this is the richest area of
the country you can see 1.5 million
people over there so as inflation bites
as people become poorer the cost of
living crisis could become part of the
NHS crisis too